sí
en el vídeo anterior vimos este segmento
de una toma de buscando a nemo donde
dibujamos las partículas como pelotas
para ilustrar su movimiento para la toma
final utilizamos la posición de las
partículas para calcular una superficie
y luego renderizados esa superficie para
que se asemeje al agua
para dibujar una superficie lisa cuando
usamos partículas individuales
utilizamos una analogía referente al
calor
primero imagina que estas partículas son
pequeños calentadores luego haz de
cuenta que tenemos un termómetro que nos
indica la temperatura de cualquier punto
en el espacio por ejemplo las partículas
podrían estar exactamente a 1000 grados
pero conforme nos vamos alejando los
objetos se van enfriando digamos que
este punto de kim está exactamente a 100
grados y bueno no es el único punto en
el espacio que está a esta temperatura
sino que hay varios entonces si unimos
todos los puntos que según el termómetro
están a 100 grados obtendremos una curva
que aquí mostramos en color amarillo y
ese es el truco ahora podemos rellenar
esta curva amarilla con un color azul
sólido que nos dará algo que se parece
más a un charco de agua
si las partículas están muy separadas
cada una constituye su propia área
aislada como una gota conforme se van
acercando las gotas empiezan a unirse y
luego a formar agua de verdad aquí
realmente tenemos una versión con unas
cuantas partículas más esto comienza a
verse como agua realmente podría verse
como agua si tuviéramos unos cuantos
miles de partículas para usarla en
nuestras películas
trabajamos en tres dimensiones y
entonces la curva se convierte en una
superficie como en esta toma de buscando
a dorín o en esta simulación de agua aún
más extraña también de buscando a dorín
este es un ejemplo de monsters
university aquí simulamos pintura en
lugar de agua aumentamos la viscosidad
porque la pintura es más viscosa que el
agua
no estábamos totalmente seguros de cómo
se comportaría la pintura así que una de
las primeras cosas que hicimos para
crear esta toma fue grabar en vídeo un
referente con pintura real esto nos
ayudó mucho para crear una imagen
creíble hagamos una pausa aquí para que
puedas practicar con el siguiente
ejercicio buena suerte